Voiceover:We're told given g of x
is equal to ten of x minus
three pi over two plus six,
find the g inverse of x.
They want us to type that in here
and then they also want us to figure out
what is the domain of g inverse,
the domain of g inverse of x.
I've got my little scratch pad here
to try to work that through.
Let's figure out what g inverse of x is.
This is g of x, so g inverse of x.
Essentially, let me just read
this is g of x right over here,
g of x is equal to tangent of x
minus three pi over two plus six.
G inverse of x, I
essentially can swap the …
I can replace the x
with the g inverse of x
and replace to g of x with an x
and then solve for g inverse of x.
I could write that x is equal
to tangent of g inverse of x
minus three pi over two plus six.
Let's just solve for g inverse of x.
I actually encourage
you to pause this video
and try to work through this
out or work it out on your own.
Let's subtract six from both sides
to at least get rid of this six here
so I'm left with x minus
six is equal to the tangent
of g inverse of x minus three pi over two.
Now let's take the inverse tangent
of both sides of this equation
so the inverse tangent
on the left hand side
is the inverse tangent of x minus six
and on the right hand side the
inverse tangent of tangent.
If we restrict the
domain in the proper way
and we'll talk about that in a little bit
is just going to be what the input
into the tangent function is.
If you restrict the
domain in the right way,
inverse tangent of the
tangent of something,
let's say theta is just
going to be equal to theta.
Once again if we restrict the domain,
if we restrict what the possible values
of theta are in the right way.
Let's just assume that we're doing that
and so the inverse
tangent of the tan, of this
is going to be just this
stuff right over here.
It's just going to be that,
it's going to be g inverse of x
minus three pi over two.
Now we're in the [home] stretch
to solve for g inverse of x
we could just add three
pi over two to both sides
so we get and actually let
me just swap both sides.
We get g inverse of x is equal to
the inverse tangent of x minus six
and then we're adding three
pi over two to both sides
so this side is now on this side
so plus three pi over two.
Let me actually type that
and I'm going to see if I can remember it
because I'm about to
lose this on my screen
so inverse tangent of x minus
six plus three pi over two
so let me write that down.
Let me type this.
G inverse of x is going
to be the inverse tangent
so I can write it like this,
the inverse tangent of x minus six
and yes it interpreted it correctly.
Inverse tangent you can do that as
arctangent of x minus six
plus three pi over two
and it did interpret it correctly
but then we have to think about
what is the domain of g inverse?
What is the domain of g inverse of x?
Let's think about this a little bit more.
The domain of g inverse of x,
so let's just think about
what tangent is doing.
The tangent function if
we imagine a unit circle,
so that's a unit circle right over there.
Guess we can imagine to be a unit circle.
My pen tool is acting up a little bit
it's putting this little gaps and things
but I think we can power through that.
Let's just say for the sake of argument
that that's a unit circle,
that's the x axis and that's the y axis.
If you form an angle theta.
If you form some angle
theta right over here,
the tangent of theta is
essentially the slope
of this terminal ray
of the angle or the ...
Or I guess we can call it the
terminal ray of the angle.
The angles form by that ray
and this ray along the positive x axis.
The tangent of theta is
the slope right over there
and you can get a tangent of
any theta except for a few.
You can find the tangent of that,
you could find the slope there,
you could also find the slope there,
you could find the slope there
but the place where you
can't find the slope
is when this ray goes straight up,
or this ray goes straight down.
Those were the cases where
you can't find the slope.
They are the slope you
could say is approaching
positive or negative infinity.
The domain of tangent, so tangent domain
so the domain is essentially
all real numbers,
all reals except multiples of pi over …
I guess you can say pi over
two plus multiples of pi,
except pi over two plus multiples of pi
where k could be any integer
so you could also be subtracting pi
because if you have pi over two,
if you add pi, you go straight down here.
You add another pi you go up there,
if you subtract pi you go down here,
add, subtract another
pi you go over there.
This is the domain
but given this domain you
can get any real number.
The range here is all reals
because you can get any slope here,
you can increase theta if
you want a really high slope,
decrease theta if you want
a really negative slope
right over there.
You can really get to anything.
Now when you're taking
about the inverse tangent,
by convention you're going to …
Well to make tangent invertible
so that you don't have multiple elements
of your domain all mapping
to the same element
of the range because for example,
this angle right over here
has the exact same slope
as this angle right over here.
If you have two theta's
mapping to the same tangent
then that's not, if you
don't restrict your domain
so that you only have one of them,
it's not going to be invertible
so the convention is is that
to make tangent invertible
you restrict its domain
to the interval from negative pi over two
to pi over two in order to
construct the inverse tangent.
The inverse tangent, you can input
any real number into it
so the inverse tangent's domain,
this is just the convention.
They could have restricted
tangents domains
as long as for any theta,
there's only one theta
in that domain that maps to a
specific element of the range
but the convention is,
well inverse tangent can …
The convention is to
restrict tangents domain
between negative pi over
two and pi over two.
Inverse tangents domain is all reals
but its range is restricted.
Its range and this is by convention
it's going to be between
negative pi over two
and pi over two and not including them.
Le'’s go back to our original
question right over here,
what is the domain of g inverse?
Let's look at our domain of g inverse,
well g inverse the domain of this
I could put any real number in here.
Now what this is going to pop out
is going to be something
between negative pi
over two and pi over two
but they're not asking us
the range of g inverse.
Actually would have been a
more interesting question.
They're asking us what's
the domain of g inverse
and I could put in any real
number right here for x,
so let's put that in here.
Domain of g inverse of x,
it's negative infinity to infinity
but actually just for fun
and let's just verify that
we got the question right
and we did
but just for fun.
Actually I am curious,
let's think about what
the range of g inverse is.
The range of this thing right over here
is going to be between
negative pi over two
to pi over two, that's for
this part right over here
and then we're going to add
three pi over two's to it.
The range for the entire function,
so the range for this
thing is going to be,
what the low end if we add
three pi over two to this,
this is going to give us two pi over two
which is just going to be,
so three pi over two minus pi over two
is going to be two pi
over two which is just pi,
just pi all the way to three pi over two
plus another pi over two is
going to be four pi’s over two
or two pi.
The range of g inverse
of x is pi to two pi
and it's an open interval.
Doesn't include the boundaries
but its domain you could
put any value for x here
and it will be defined.